giraffe - Player 01KA8MJT8GB1R02FGWGTEKABKQ:At
transcript:1
giraffe - Player 01KA8MJT8GB1R02FGWGTEKABKQ:Right?
transcript:2
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:I
transcript:3
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:Parents were
transcript:4
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:I'm an elephants.
transcript:5
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:Hello.
transcript:6
giraffe - Player 01KA8MJT8GB1R02FGWGTEKABKQ:I am still a giraffe.
transcript:7
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:One two
transcript:8
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:three
transcript:9
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:four
transcript:10
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:on
transcript:11
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:six.
transcript:12
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:Again.
transcript:13
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:One two three
transcript:14
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:five
transcript:15
elephant - Player 01KA8MJT9PTD8EV6QY7T45A48H:seven eight.